Camila thank you so much for sitting
with me thank you so much for having me
I'm so excited to be here of course so I
want to first talk about what exactly
your company does can you explain sonoro
for me yeah so sonoro is a global
entertainment company so we develop
audio first IP so Concepts that start as
podcast primarily with latino creators
around the world so in English Spanish
or bilingual and then we take that IP
and develop it into TV film books event
series merchandise eard basically
everything under the sun tell me about
your founding story what were you doing
before and then how did this company
come about I've always been in love with
storytelling that's what brings me the
most passion and the most Joy so I
always knew I wanted to do something in
the entertainment or storytelling space
right after college my first job was
actually a non-fiction storytelling so I
was at the LA times for about four years
in that sort of Journey I came across
audio and podcasting as this really
great way to develop IP and make it grow
and and sort of enhance the audience
that we already had and so in 2017 I was
part of the team that launched dirty
John which was the first podcast LA
Times ever produced it was this insane
True Crime Story and it was sort of a
runaway success today it has over 80
million downloads and that was the first
time that I saw audio as an IP property
being used to develop all different
types of Medias and to me that was like
a very big sort of aha moment that as
someone that always loves stories and
content this was sort of like the next
Frontier or the next medium where that
experimentation and excitement was going
to come from so I spent the next sort of
three years launching about a dozen
podcasts with the LA times and then at
that point sort of felt ready to go and
build something more from the ground up
it was a little bit of mini startup
within a larger organization at the time
and and gave me I think the
entrepreneurial itch to to really get
with my co-founders and start Toral very
cool now there's so many podcast
companies out there today obviously a
lot of entertainment companies as well
how do you stand out from like the Wes
of the world or or other companies is
doing similar things but maybe through a
different lens yeah I think for us first
and foremost we really believe ourselves
to be an entertainment company so for us
audio is really just that first step we
want everything to exist beyond that and
like I said it can be TV it can be film
which is more what you've traditionally
seen podcasts become but this month we
launched our first graphic novel which
is based on a podcast that we produced
we have Live Events and tours with some
of our podcasters that we're producing
as well going into next year and then
separately of course for us the focus
really is the Latino Community around
the world and there's 500 million Global
Spanish speakers 60 million us Latinos
so for us that is our big
differentiator so now I want to talk
about your fundraising Journey can you
tell me about how much you've raised and
what the process has been like for you
yeah so today we've raised about $13
million so our primary investors are lir
hippo and founder Collective and grcraft
we have some really excellent media
investors and again I've been very lucky
to have some great co-founders to go on
that Journey with and I think that in a
way we were familiar and unfamiliar as a
country right like people understood at
the time we launched March 2020 at that
point there had been audio I know right
that's a fun time to launch a company
interesting timing but people understood
conceptually to a certain extent the
audio to TV and film Pipeline and I
think where we had to sort of do more
education in our pitches frankly was
we're going beyond that we really are
thinking about this as a global
entertainment company that's developing
not just TV and film but all of these
other mediums and focusing on This
Global Community talk to me a little bit
about your audience you know how many is
it how many in the US how many globally
and who are the types of people that
you're you're trying to reach yeah so
today we have over 25 million Global
downloads so that is across Mexico and
Latin America primarily Mexico and then
us Latino so we're split about 8020 to
latam and the us and our audience is
Young I mean they're typically 18 to 35
they're in the bigger cities in the US
they are where you would expect them to
be for primarily sort of Latino
dominated cities in California Arizona
New York Florida Etc but they're young
and they're sort of excited and they're
diverse last question for you what do
you want your legacy to be I mean so I
was just a little nerd when I was young
I was incredibly nerdy I was uh like I
said I like loved fanfiction and SciFi
and fantasy and all that stuff and part
of the reason why I focused on
storytelling as sort of the through line
of my career and sort of personal
choices and interests is because I just
love the way a great story makes me feel
and I think like a lot of the community
that is built online around those things
is really special for a lot of people
especially that are outcasts when
they're growing up and so I think I hope
that my legacy with sonoro and Beyond
really is either facilitating or being a
part of making these great shows that
make people feel the same way I feel
when I read a really great
[Music]
book
oh